I'm champagne Jane my question is
related to your original business the
one that obviously stimulated me all
those years ago one library TV yes I
started my youtube channel thanks to you
thank you um when you want to change the
market
I mean you changed the way people
communicated online and you made it
accessible you obviously had the back
end because you had the business selling
wine as well if you want to change will
change the market to make I'm trying to
make champagne and accessible that gives
me problems with the industry that want
to keep it kind of aspirational and so
on so forth
don't you douche bags yeah yeah I agree
what would I do yeah so we talked a
little bit so I have even more context I
think what you have to do any time you
want to disrupt something and you're
getting restriction or or pushback from
people within the market that are
stopping you so to get very technical
for you if you're trying to demystify
champagne and the champagne industry
makes all their money by the
mystification so that's the reason
they're able to charge those prices your
problem is they don't support you
they're not gonna give you money they're
not gonna give you samples they're not
going to give you products for events
they're not gonna support you there's a
lot of people that have this problem
it's what uber went through as an
investor numr the taxi industry has been
fighting us legally paying off
politicians bad stuff right stuff that I
know the liquor industry would do to the
answer is you go around them the only
way to defeat the establishment when
they don't want you to win is to go
around them there is no peace there's no
deal
there is no appeasing you punch them in
a neck so the way you do that is you
start trying to figure out who else
aligns with your interests I'll give you
a weird one
champagne Jane what about the sparkling
wine industry in America what if you
mapped the 15 most important wine
producers in America that makes
sparkling wine or the Brazilian wine
market that's trying to make a name for
themselves so the Brazilian sparkling
wine market is trying to make a name for
themselves
you want to talk about something that
nobody takes seriously it's sparkling
wine from Brazil but you know what's
funny it's backed by the government
you know what governments have money I'm
sure if you had a conversation with them
that they made you know you're not gonna
get your money from moet you're not
gonna you're gonna get your pushback
from them you need to find whether a
retailer a distributor or some other
interested parties you need to go around
them to find the dollars that will
support you because literally you could
take the Brazilian money in marketing
and buy French Champagne if you need it
for events or sampling it on your show
right I mean English sparkling lines a
perfect example I mean so I think you're
you you need to say go [ __ ] yourself to
the champagne market we need to realize
they're dramatically less powerful than
you think they are that's the first
thing you need to do because I talk to
you I know you feel they are I'm telling
you they're not and you need to feel
like a copy MW can give you the money
the BMW can think that they're
associated to champagne like we need to
think outside your box you got it